good evening London welcome to Facebook
and uncensored I'm going to tell you a
little story it's about an advertising
campaign so helplessly woken absurd but
I'm convinced it was designed
specifically to irritate me not long ago
in a large glass building filled with
smug people and kale smoothies the
marketing team at HSBC commissioned a
children's author to rewrite three
classic fairy tales you might well think
that's an unusual thing for a bank to do
if you're sitting comfortably I'll allow
them to explain
with financial attitude shaped as early
as five years old the new book
challenges traditional gender
stereotypes it says at this point I've
already lost track really of exactly why
the bank is rewriting fairy tales or
what any of it has got to do with gender
stereotypes but it gets worse the book
called fairer fairer Tales reimagined
Cinderella Sleeping Beauty and Rapunzel
a successful businesswoman Prince
Charming is inevitably erased as the
main character he's a prince and he's
Charming but apparently that's not
enough the marketing Geniuses decided to
pay tennis player emeralda kanu to read
the stories reasons which remain unclear
this is how it went
Ace where have you been the boys and
girls are here and they're waiting to
hear the three Tails about
money
my name's Emma and this is Ace we have a
fantastic story for you today now the
story may seem like one you know but the
characters in it are a little bit
different
it's hard to believe that the tennis
ball exchanging hilarious banter with
emerald akanu in the video is not real
it's CGI Believe It or Not Emma is a
tennis player not an actor but let's not
distract from the powerful core message
so in the end the princesses didn't need
a prince to save them they set up their
own businesses save their money and then
spent it very wisely
[Music]
thanks to our princesses Aces learned
some new money skills maybe you'll buy a
tower one day or set up your own shoe
business or any business you want
now that you've learned how to save and
spend money you can do anything
of course as we all know the best way to
improve the aspirations of women is by
trashing men and as Emma says women
don't need men at all she certainly
never needed any men as far as we know
to get where she is today except well a
father of course who manages her career
and well fathered her and then there are
her five coaches who so far have all
been male or Max Eisenberg her agent who
apparently is very very good at
maximizing her earning potential despite
being a man and then a final Twist of
his dastardly tale of virtue signaling
treasury it turns out the chairman chief
executive and Chief Financial Officer on
hsbc's board of directors are all men
too well joining me now is taught to be
contributor Esther cracker Associated to
the mirror Kevin McGuire socialist
author Grace Blakely Grace
uh I don't know where to start with this
I mean part of the fact that as a man
let me just offer Miss rather Garden
some advice I think she's great uh and
when she won the US Open it was amazing
but she hasn't won a shoebox since then
and I think she's spending too much time
on this commercial stuff and not enough
time on the call that's my personal view
as a man take it leave it crash it
whatever you want I think you're missing
actually the most important part of this
story right which isn't like the the big
man versus women battle that we're all
supposed to take aside in it's about
that HSBC is a massive International you
know bank that has frequently been
accused of uh things like money
laundering it was accused of money
laundering for Mexican drug cartels it
was accused of supporting tax avoidance
and evasion it's frequently threatened
the government of the UK to relocate to
another part of the world if it if we
you know um say do something like raise
tax tax on corporations or if we start
regulating financial sector properly and
this is basically attempt an attempt to
kind of pink washing it saying don't
look at all the terrible things that
we've been embroiled in over the last
several decades don't look at the fact
that we're basically trying to undermine
democracy by by telling you what laws
you can and can't pass just look at the
fact that we've done a nice pretty
little fairy tale and oh by the way if
you're a woman and you start a business
then that's great and that makes you a
good woman feminism isn't for people who
don't get the chance to stop and it
certainly isn't a great thing to be a
woman at HSBC where the vast majority of
the people that run the bank are
actually men I mean that's the problem
with this it's a bit like Barbie the
movie it's a bit like all these things
there's a kind of subtext here of well
men are pointless and annoying and you
should never not just rely on them but
have them in your life because they
sponge men from the world and all will
be fine well yes but I think that we
should be more concerned with why a bank
or any business feels the need to
actually do this I I don't remember
asking HSBC what they think about fairy
tales or women in business or anything
like that why can't they just be a
business why do businesses feel the need
to to lecture us or take a particular
political position as if we need them as
our more
I totally agree I mean Kevin is that all
right Kevin we've seen this time and
again now companies just doing these
woke advertising campaigns none of which
work right there's an immediate backlash
from all their customers who don't like
this kind of thing I think it's a
growing number of people whether you're
Bud Light or Gillette when they play
this stunt or any of these others now we
have this it's not going to work it's
not going to achieve what they think it
is people aren't going to go fantastic
age busy they're I going to say what
Grace said which is you're just a bunch
of flaming Hypocrites or they're going
to say stop talking to me about this
stuff just make my bank do do its job be
a banker that's why I love it because it
backfires it is entirely cynical by this
bank which look you open a business with
them you can't keep up your repayments
on a loan and they'll have you they'll
have the shirt off your back they'll
have your handbag your shoes I love your
house they'll have every lust any you've
got but somehow there's a whole industry
convincing them they should do this
a good look to the advertising people
who get them to do this can I just say
uh I've kudos to emiraticanu's agent for
actually getting her this morning
because she's a terrible actress she
looks like as wooden as a board and she
doesn't think I believe what she's
reading I think there is an important
underlying story here right which is the
reason that we've had this explosion and
kind of you know green washing pink
washing things like ethical consumption
is that most people realize that the
system we live in is incredibly unfair
they want to you know do things to
support to prevent climate breakdown
they want to do things to support you
know equal rights and and prevent you
know the economy from privileging
certain people over others and
corporations are basically trying to
make money out of this just like they're
making money out of the climate work
dying just like they're making money out
of the gap between between